can bounce back um
wow this is knight g4 i think this is an
unbelievable turnaround i mean you know
one would have to look at this game
in serious detail to understand it but
yeah
okay knight f4 knight d5 is coming in
knight f4 hits the rook on e2 the knight
is going to attack the other rook and c7
uh i think ali reza is going to beat the
world champion
uh clock times tanya 33 seconds for ali
raza
24 for magnus um this is extraordinary
um rook h2 hits the knights
uh i mean he could take he could just
play rook h2 to hit the knight he's
he would he would be attacking both
pieces i don't see what's
real change to knight d1 looks like the
only way to continue no okay
the knight d1 but then then we have uh
rook c1
and well again there's there's two
pieces attacked i mean
this this could be game over this is
unbelievable
yeah game over oh my god
got it a star danny what a start
ali reza starts the event
by beating world champion magnus
constant what a game that was not just
the result but what a brilliant game